started a few people will come in late
let's go ahead and get started uh it's a
pleasure to have
christos here today or not really here
today but online with us today
um i'm trying to keep the introductions
brief but let me just say a couple words
anyway and then we'll let
christos talk um so christos is well
known for his extensive work
in theory of computer science and logic
um
he's a recipient of quite a few prizes
many of them named after famous people
i'll mention a few of them the ieee von
neumann prize
the girdle prize charles babbage fries
the knuth prize
among others um i first met him when he
was
teach i think since i first met him was
teaching at ucsd
at uc san san diego when i joined as a
young young faculty member and he helped
me get settled in even though he was in
a different department for me
and since then he's taught at athens and
berkeley and is now at
at columbia uh he's speaking to us
about total functions beyond np
so go ahead christos you have the floor
thanks sam uh uh thanks for bringing
about
bad back memories and and uh
hello everybody delighted to be here i'm
missing the
the simon's uh
uh semesters and uh i'm i'm sorry i'm
missing the
simon's such semester so um
some correctly named my my uh
my title but in fact i'm going to talk
about more
uh i'm going to talk about first of all
i'm going to honor
the anniversary we're celebrating uh
and uh tell you about sort of you know
the
uh i guess i may be one of the older
speakers so i can tell you what
you know what was happening
back then as i remember it uh i'll
talk about some recent work and then i'm
talk you know my
last slide is about some exciting very
recent work okay so um
okay uh just to remember you know
before 1971 our world
was very simple okay so in fact
this was a war this was our world but we
didn't know it
okay so um you know computer scientists
was not were not working on this problem
computer scientists were working on
automata theory and switching theory on
sort of abstract software and abstract
hardware
uh and these concepts pnp and
the polynomial hierarchy were given to
us by
logicians recursion theorists
optimization people
mathematicians okay so and then a few
things happened
and the two things that i believe
completely changed the landscape
were were cooked theorem
and carp theorem that that followed and
strassen's algorithm okay because it was
these two things okay that
that that made
theoreticians who as i told you up to
them were not working on computation
believe it or not
say wow there is amazing mathematical
depth
in computation so you know you can you
can run
you can create by doing combinatorics
new mathematics
and and new lower bounds to you know so
this was this was transformative okay
and
uh i don't know how many of you are
aware
but uh this happened okay the same year
steve published a paper in jsm
which i believe was a precursor of his
of his of his
of his uh sad paper uh
and basically i mean i don't know how
many of you knew but
but uh steve cook at that point he was
the best
uh pushdown automata hacker so you know
so he was coming up with beautiful
algorithm based on gustan automata
and and then he said what what if we
give them some
logarithm logarithmic space
to help them and he noticed that
that non-deterministic push
becoming p and deterministic push become
p
and this is of course scary because
push down automata not determinism does
not does not help okay but
but apparently not if you give them some
space to work with so
so this was so close to the pig was a
big question so you know it was coming
from a completely different
direction which i remind you was what
most computer scientists were were
obsessed with
at that time all right so uh and uh
so uh the amazing thing about
the pnmp and epic completeness is it's
uh
incredibly sort of unreasonably
unreasonable power classification power
okay
in other words you look at the problem
chances are it's either in p or it's mp
complete
this was carbs incredible contribution
carp read the cook's paper looked around
him and noticed the following amazing
thing
that he knew about 50 problems
half of them he could solve half of them
he would not
well they were all and be complete
and he published this finding and this
finding sort of paid the way
to our mode of operation for the next 50
years okay
and and there were two problems that he
that that he could not classify and he
brought them in he put them he mentions
them in the in the post-scripture movies
of his paper
with uh sort of with annoyance okay as
if as if he is
truly annoyed that that these things
refuse to be classified and this is
these are i believe
uh factoring and graph isomorphic okay
so indeed so
as you know uh uh recursion theory
predicts
that there are infinitely many
intermediate degrees between
pnmp so you know you would expect
a tiny fraction of problems in np to be
solvable in polynomial time
and a tiny fraction would be completed
that's not what happens okay but
you know the the intermediate degrees
are almost
eclipsed i mean where do they manifest
themselves and they do manifest
themselves
these are problems which seem hard
but but could not be complete and you
realize this very early because then our
world would collapse the polynomial
hierarchy would collapse
and of these it turns out that
30 years ago probably to the day uh
with numerous megiddo it realized that
there we had this
these total functions all right i mean
most of them except for graph
isomorphism
we have we have uh total functions okay
that the witness always exists all right
i mean
and our original problems are that we've
discussed we're factoring
uh a problem uh a linear programming
like problem
and and the nasa equilibrium okay
actually the nasa equilibrium
for both of us was was the reason why we
felt obliged to define this class
uh so um
and so uh i mean fine you know
we have a we have a sort of better
picture uh
that there is this class tfmp and and
this little pimple on it
the graphite some more these problems
which still resist classification so you
know it's probably much closer to np
than you think to p than we think
uh and i mean immediately the question
was
we do believe uh in the our heart of
hearts
that these problems are interactable
madam you know how do you prove them
interactability
in tfnp and the first thought is to
prove them cfmp complete but
cmp please is unlikely to have complete
problems
so and over the years the following
methodology for classifying total
problems
in np uh took
a form that you look at its proof of
brutality
if it's constructive the search is over
the problem is indeed
and if it's not constructive then you
may have discovered a new complexity
class okay so this was this was working
for a few years until you realized
the following curious fact that for for
almost all known heart problems in tfmp
the only non-constructive step in the
existence proof
is one of very few and very obvious
existential theorems the physical
principle
any graph has a need a number of both
nodes and after here means that
there is there is one such pro one such
class for every parity for every for
every uh
modulus uh every path must end somewhere
and every day has a sink okay so these
were the only
uh the only specimens that we that we
that we that
that we that we have found uh
and and uh notice
that all of them are finitely in other
words they are uh
they are uh properties that hold for
all finite finite structures but fail
for infinite structures all of them
and there is a good reason for that okay
with with with paul goldberg we have a
little theorem
inspired by herb brandt's theorem that
says that
if if uh if a non-financi
uh uh if if
if this property is non-financing then
the corresponding class
is collapses into p okay it's
necessarily polynomial
in fact tfnp has
a lot of a lot of a lot of subclasses
that have been noted up until now
and they correspond to these to these uh
interesting uh uh interesting
existential
proof uh arguments uh combinatorial
simple combinatorial arguments that i uh
showed you uh we know these inclusions
that i show
uh there are oracle separations from
almost everything else that i know
um and in fact some have natural
complete problems okay
what do i mean by natural complex
problems frankly i mean the following
i call a problem my working definition
is i call a problem
natural complete problem if i was
interested in the problem before i
started thinking about the complete
problems for the class okay so uh
so if they do have natural complete
problems and
perhaps the most the most distinguished
among them is the nash equilibrium
problem
uh uh to remind you in 1950
nas changed the world of economics by
proposing the nash equilibrium concept
which amazingly
a simple rather obvious generalization
of
max mean that that had escaped from
neumann's attention
and also proved that like facts mean
it's universal in other words that
all games have one uh uh half a century
later
and after nas had obtained the nobel
prize for this
uh uh meyerson wrote
and wrote that nasa's theorem lies at
the foundations of modern economic
thought here is what he meant
and he explains it that it is the
universality of nasa's theorem
is the one that gives economists a
license when they contemplate a design
or a market or a situation to sit back
and think
let's see what happens at equilibrium
okay and and
this enabled in some sense all of modern
economics including equilibrium theory
in
in in markets in price equilibrium
theory
uh and you know so
a few years later uh with with
with the skeletes and goldberg we prove
that it's intractable all right i mean
also
and just to
interactable of course means ppid
complete which
in our mind is a form of intractability
you know
it you know we firmly believe that that
ppad is not imp
but uh i mean especially the students of
sat
uh like you uh know very well
that in practice interpretability means
nothing right i mean all that that there
can be
whole uh industries uh
uh based on the solution of intractable
problems okay and then
you know that okay so so what why is
this
you know and and my here is here is here
is why i believe
why i believe uh we have a point uh
that this is true in practice but in
theory
you see what i mean uh the nas
equilibrium is not a practical concept
the
the mass equilibrium is a practical is a
theoretical tool
okay and that's what meyerson says in
his 1999 article
and that's actually a fact this is how
it's used
in some sense interactability means that
nasa's theorem is as if it said that uh
almost every game has enough equilibrium
uh which would have had
much much much less impact
and and and and and
effect on on the development of
economics
okay in fact
[Music]
they all have natural complete problems
now okay so you know the
science has progressed uh uh paul
goldberg and his group
so you know they have been and his
co-authors have been finding
have been populating uh all of these
classes with with complete problems the
last couple of years
okay cool
um so uh
how about the polynomial hierarchy okay
you know sometimes
i wonder could could could you have
could you have meaningful
total problems up there and you do okay
and that's
that's a paper that we presented last
month at itcs
with bobby kleiberg you know uh
danny troposki is a third year graduate
student of mine
and oliver corton is a first-year
phd student of mine so we published this
paper
where basically uh
we talk about the empty pigeonhole
principle in other words
if there are more pigeonholes than
pigeons then one pigeonhole will be
empty
and and it is this one because it has a
universal quantifier okay so
you know it is in cf sigma 2p okay
and sometimes you call it the union
bound class because that's what is the
bodies okay it's
all problems uh all existential problems
that can be solved through the union
bound
and it turns out that that it contains
all of fnp
why because sat reduces to the empty
pigeonhole principle it's it's quite
easy it's an easy exercise to think
about it
and it has natural problems none of
them known to be complete uh remote
point in other words find
given a code find a point that is away
from every code word
remote node given a graph bounded degree
find a a
a note given a succinct graph of course
you know find find the node who is who
is uh
as far away as the diameter of the graph
has to be
uh complexity i'm going to define it i
mean we have a problem called the
complexities class
rigid matrix completion um
[Music]
so you know there are a lot of a lot of
a lot of you know
everything that is proved through the
union bound has a hazard has
it has a representative there uh let me
tell you about
complexity uh here is a complex problem
complexity given a string x of length n
and i warn you that x will act
both as a uh a definer of the
of the of the number of inputs and also
as
a as a normal okay so you want to find
the truth table
t of a function with
logan variables boolean variables such
that
these truth tables cannot be computed by
circuits
with a few gates essentially as many as
as shannon's argument gives you and
this count of gates includes oracle
gates
whose truth table is the input x okay so
this was the problem we defined and it
of course it fits
well into into this class uh
the problem the real problem okay so
we know is what what you can call
epsilon hard
which is a and it's the following
given to any unary find the truth table
of n boolean functions or n variables or
boolean of actual variables
uh that cannot be computed by circuits
with two to the epsilon and gates okay
and
in fact that's exactly the problem that
impaired vidcon used
in 98 to uh
to get through the randomness and
and complex our problem complexity was
an attempt
at a non-sparse version uh and
exponential below so
you know for expository purposes okay so
that's
that's how you should look at the
complexity uh the complexity problem
that i mentioned before okay
cool uh and
the subset of the class pep which
corresponds to the polynomial
empty piece of principle uh uh
a stands for abundant or if you wish
wasteful
uh you have two n pigeons and
one plus alpha two to the end pigeon
holes okay and
alpha ranges from one over poly to two
to the n if alpha is one over x
it becomes pep okay but if it's one over
poly
uh up to up to even exponential it
becomes it becomes uh
um uh uh up okay
the the the waste is sort of you know
the the wasteful abundant
pigeonhole principle and contains most
of these problems
and very importantly it's closed after
fp to the np reductions
fp to the np uh we don't know if it's
close at the under under
under under p reduction so we wonder uh
but but it is closed under fp to the
imperial actions and these kinds of
reductions
uh are really
a little attractive for this context and
of course quite a bit more powerful than
peer reductions
was the question oh there's some
questions in the chat window let's see
is is is anyone that
that seems urgent um
i think it could wait if you like if you
want to keep going it's
well i'll tell you the question our tfmp
problem is morally similar to hash
functions
yeah tf problems um
well in some sense yeah oh that was
meant just for me but okay you can
answer it anyway
okay okay uh i mean a good question um
uh there is a large huge subclass of
tfmp
uh that is hash functions okay so you
know it's it's called
it's called the pigeonhole the
pigeonhole class okay you know so
uh yes i mean there they are they are
and in fact the pigeonhole class is our
greatest hope right now
to get probably intractable uh pidgeoth
classes
uh sorry hash functions so yes i mean
also there is a there is a big
connection which i'm not
i'm not i'm not i'm not
i'm not talking about now between tfmp
especially pvp
and cryptography hash functions and so
on but we know but but thanks for
bringing it up
okay thanks christos it was vijay here
who asked the question
okay thank you sure
um anything else here
uh okay good so uh it's close that there
are okay under uh and and and
and uh so
this class appeb if you wish is a class
of explicit constructions
for non-constructive arguments okay
these are some of the most revered
problems computer science
and so it is with a lot of
respect for the question we are asking
does a pep have complete problems okay
in other words
what is the hardest explicit
construction okay and
in our paper uh we
incidentally with uh with uh with uh
kleinberg
uh oliver courtney i believe is in the
audience
uh uh metropolis myself
which you presented a month ago we uh
the conjecture that complexity is up
complete
under fp to the np reductions okay uh
so that's that that was in some sense
the main conjecture
but really which is the main outcome of
that paper okay so you know
identifying complexity as a candidate to
be
uh a pep complete under under these
these powerful reductions
uh so uh
are there any interesting uh problems
further up
and the answer is yes we found we found
a couple that are
quite cool and i'm going to tell you uh
the source
it says that any family f with more than
n to the d sets shutters some dead
uh set uh s of of
uh d elements okay and uh
and not the quantifiers okay there are
there there is for all there exists
a set d with the element such that for
every subset
s of d there is a set in f that
generates s by intersection of b with d
so
these are you have really the three
alternation of quantifiers that
that that you want to see if you are
talking about the problem in
uh tf sigma 3 p now okay so it's higher
than
what we have been arguing before and
therefore the problem is ourselves which
is give me explicitly this shuttered set
is in sigma t f sigma three p
okay and in our paper uh we are proving
a difficult theorem uh so you know it
requires some interesting combinatorics
and computation
to that source
is not just in tf sigma-3p
but is in the pigeonhole principle
except that
the circuit that computes the hash
function if you wish
uh has a sigma two or has access to
sigma to oracle
okay so uh so it's uh so we know
in some sense exactly where sauer salaf
belongs and i'm curious if it could ever
be
complete for this class okay
another problem in tf sigma 3
is
so
basically it is it is
it is the problem we call king okay so
i mean it's a it's a fun it's a fun uh
combinatorial problem so i will explain
to you
you know the tournament is it is a click
on which
on which uh all all uh
all uh games have been decided so it's a
click
with uh with a direction in every age
uh and we are given a tournament which
of course is
is compactly is is succinct okay succeed
means that
that if you give me
two logan beats describing an edge i'll
give you the direction of that
so and what is a king in a tournament
a king in a tournament is a vertex a
player
who is two victories away from everybody
so
if i'm a king either i have beat you
either i beat you
or i have beaten somebody who beat you
and it turns out that every tournament
has a king and here is the proof
okay it's it's a it's a extremely simple
proof like
some of these all of these all of these
subtle functions
uh am i a king maybe i am
maybe i'm not if i'm not there is
somebody else
uh who i have not beaten and who is not
has beaten everybody that i have beaten
okay now
if i go if if the algorithm uh
turns its attention from me to the other
this other person
okay then uh the people
who have been beaten or have been beaten
by somebody
he has beaten increases by at least one
okay and so this has to stop at some
point
and and and the fixed point will be a
king
all right it's uh it's it's a it's a
extremely elementary proof like always
and uh uh for every other player you
know it is
tf sigma three uh there is another
player who beat them but was beaten by
the king or is a king okay so that's
that's what
that's what king means and therefore it
is in tf sigma 3p
uh in fact amino this looks very much
like the class pls of
of of
local search um but it's a little more
complicated we discuss it a little in
opera in our paper
uh there are there is something more to
say here it's not exactly
pls with a sigma two oracle it's
something
quite a bit more complicated okay
um right so uh so these are these are
the these are the problems that
uh that uh uh
and and so i described you what i call
the recent results now
now i'm going to tell you about a very
recent result uh
uh let's recall the conjecture okay it's
it's
as i told you the main conjecture the
main outcome of that of that
paper in tf in in
itcs we conjecture that
that complexity is app complete under
fp38b functions and with
oliver corton my student hello we have
been
thinking about that until suddenly
two weeks ago oliver came up with a
very interesting proof uh very cool
proof
that not just complexity but epsilon
hard
is up complete under fp to the np
reductions okay so
uh it's uh it's uh you know so in some
sense
we uh we propose an answer to the
question what is the most
what's the most the hardest
hardest
explicit construction problem okay
so and the paper is in preparation
all right uh i think i
i closed my the path that i promised let
me
let's let's uh uh
remember what what we discussed uh half
a century ago it was
you know as i told you it was it was a
huge turning point for theoretical
computer science in many ways the birth
of theoretical computer science okay
and i you know i believe that the
landmarks that
that that that that that created this
is the cook carp 11 theorem
and strassen's algorithm okay that
basically
suddenly the it became obvious
that there is
[Music]
incredible depth mathematical depth and
combinatorial complexity
in trying to understand computation okay
it's it's rich in its limits
and and so we are celebrating not just
sat who are celebrating
the birth of our field i believe i
believe
so 30 years ago
total functions were born and they have
come a long way since then okay so since
uh
megiddo and i uh proposed them proposed
the class so we know and the concept
you know basically
the the main impetus
was the nas equilibrium problem
which was uh proposed to both of us
uh by uh independently by uh
kenneth arrow okay sorry around that
time
as something as a problem that
sorely needed computational scrutiny
and and and so total functions have
have become much more uh
full of results including including uh
conclusive results about
about uh
[Music]
the nash equilibrium problem i should
add that
that that three years ago
the remaining open problem regarding the
nash equilibrium problem i should have
added this
in my slide was resolved by my former
student
abiad rubinstein it is not only
intractable but also intractable to
approximate within any constant function
so you know it's very interesting that
that you have new specimens of total
functions
in the first couple of levels of the
polynomial hierarchy okay so you know so
these we thought were very cool
and and and we decided to
to explore them and this exploration
brought us close to some
deep problems in in related to
um to explicit constructions
and in fact as i told you recently
we had an inter you know we had an
interesting site in the question
what is the hardest explicit
construction okay so
that's it and thank you very much
all right thank you
thank you christos um it's hard to clap
so i'll clap for everybody
so thank you very much for very
interesting talk
um we're going to open the floor to
questions now we've got about
15 minutes or so to maybe 20 minutes for
questions and
so i'll open the floor i have a couple
burning questions myself but maybe i'll
let other people go first if they like
and otherwise i'll jump in
um well no one's jumping up fast enough
so if you're in the key oh by the way if
you're a
panelist you can either write into the
chat window
in which case try to make it visible to
everybody if you're an attendee
you need to type into the q a and we'll
and we'll read your questions for you
okay so mike my first question then is
um coming back to the question about
nash
so it's ppid complete and hard to
approximate
um does this say anything about but you
know as you're speaking to a sat
sat people who are used to solving hard
problems as you mentioned
what about solving nash is there a
theory of that that's easy to solve
on average or for special cases or for
special cases that come in practice
or that's that's a great question you
know i don't know
i don't know i mean there is there is uh
there is a there is a beautiful
combinatorial argo algorithm
um uh simplex-like algorithm that solves
it
uh and uh i mean we don't have evidence
i mean oh it's not
like linear programming okay so you know
it's not it's it's smooth complexity is
hard i mean also but
so it's not going to be as easy as as
converting simplex into into polynomial
into another polynomial time algorithm
you know it's it's it
seems to be harder than linear
programming but um
but uh it's
uh but i mean there are
i'm sure there are conjectures i don't
know if they're articulated
but there are conjectures sort of you
know circulating in the community
about the running time of this algorithm
so you know of the
of the pivoting algorithm for solving
nash
and and
i mean as as a reality check
we know that factoring reduces to nash
okay you know so so we don't expect so
we know to
to be to be to have
a very serious breakthrough uh but
uh sort of you know we we we might have
we may
might have some uh some tangible
practical
uh algorithms for nash okay but i mean
again let me
remember iterate something that i tried
to
say in that slide
nas is not enough equilibrium it's not
exactly a practical problem okay so
you know there are there is code that uh
that
that that try that finds the nas
equilibria
but uh that's not the point okay you
know the point of nash equilibrium
is its its uh
modeling power in its power for uh sort
of
uh reducing any economic situation to a
to a stable example to to an equator
okay good yeah good thanks
there's a couple chat window questions i
don't know if you can read them or not
but i will
um i think they're addressed oh um can
we change the
chat thanks be to all all panelists and
attendees instead of just all
panelists um
i don't know maybe if maybe only can
change those i don't know
any rate the first question is from
samteal
i can't see the rest of the name
do you want to ask it or shall i read it
for you
i'll go ahead and read it do you think
there's any use in defining complexity
classes where the witness
is a function like for the strategy
stealing argument where we know a
winning strategy exists we cannot
construct it easily
um for the strategy stealing argument
um that's
so i have not thought about that you
know it's it's an obvious thing to think
about
um uh i mean uh
it's uh i i don't know where i don't
know where where it belongs i mean
it it's something you know in
in
[Music]
sort of just just
[Music]
just my reaction is that that's worth
worth worth um
uh exploring and as i told you we have
we have methodology for this okay to try
to you know try
you know recite the existence proof
and find the combinatorial part that is
that is
that is resistant to a polynomial
simulation
but that's a good question so you know
i'll
i may think about it later in the day
okay
all right uh sam until writes thank you
he
couldn't ask himself having some issues
okay
um in texas maybe that's some of the
issues i'm not any right oh my god
good luck yeah yeah take care um paul
has a question do you want to ask it or
shall i read it for you
um oh
i'll go ahead and read it i guess so
paul beam writes these are great new
problems to think about
what do you think about the prospects
for carp's old annoying problem of
factoring
[Laughter]
paul uh great to hear from you um
paul beam has helped me a lot in
thinking about total functions over the
years and
has fixed a lot of bugs in my original
paper
and so you know it has has been has been
a great great discussion on total
functions
so factoring it turns out
that that
factoring uh can't be pro
randomized algorithms reduced to both
ppp
and ppid okay so factoring is not a
wrong
problem after all sort of you know it
does have some certificates of uh
belonging to to to these tfmp classes
okay so um
uh
factoring of course uh has also the dual
uh
the dual property that of being of being
solvable in
in in by
quantum computers and incidentally i
don't know
you know there is there is something um
uh you know in the old days
we used to think that these problems
like
you know and quantum computers have been
thinking about you know
people working on quantum computers have
been thinking about for example
local optima and ppid and so on okay so
there are some uh improvements but
but are you know
our total functions uh sort of you know
net
generalizing factory the next great uh
great uh
uh arena for uh quantum algorithm so we
know
it looked like that uh frankly 15 years
ago so
you know but i don't think that there
are there has been much progress
okay um
okay thank you paul did you have a
follow-up on that um
there was also while awaiting uh al
oliver corton
one of christus's co-authors comments
that there's an archive paper it's in
the q a window
showing that strategy stealing can be
p-space complete
i believe that's the right way to
summarize it i haven't really had a
chance to look at it
okay um so that's a good thing to have
um let's see
i was gonna ask also about the you have
this you proved your conjecture about
complexity being tf sigma 2p complete
just recently you announced um what
about are there do you have conjectured
complete classes for like tf sigma 3 p
so i mean yes i i
uh i i think i'm speaking for all my
co-authors
that we believe that uh that uh source
may be maybe hard for
sigma for for uh for uh ppp
for the for the p for the pigeonhole
principle
when uh when the when the
hash functions can use a sigma two
oracle
i mean that would be an amazing result
okay so you know i don't know where to
start but
but it's you know it looks it looks like
a
sort of nice general set theoretic
theorem
a lot of structure you know exactly what
what what you need to
start working on something like this
okay and um is there a
is there a sort of rep have you
considered a relativized version of
complexity where you have
non-deterministic circuits or something
like that or
and uh so i mean i mean in some sense
uh uh we devised complexity
when we characterize when you
characterize ourselves okay sort of you
know it's it's
and uh and com and and
complexity with capital so you know the
the pet problem we proposed
uh uh is relativized okay so we know
because because it's input is also an
oracle that
that feeds that feeds the oracle queries
okay you know so
so i mean yes our device has been on our
on our mind when we're doing this but
but of course
we may have missed the interesting
opportunity
okay okay so you know there is also
something else that there are
uh there are known uh
uh sort of relativization results about
tfnp
and and and uh it's uh sigma do version
and uh
sort of you know separations and
and and collapses under oracles so you
know it's
you know that it turns out that the
total function hierarchy so to speak is
a little more resistant than
to collapses than than the polynomial
okay interesting okay
we write about this we write about this
this in the paper
good good um
other let's see more questions please
speak up if you're
a panelist or type into the chat window
or the q a window if you wish
um so antonina asks aunt antonina do you
want to ask the question yourself
yeah sure um
chris that was fantastic talk i think
you remember that
you had a class at some point based on
uh based on ramsey's theorem
but today you haven't said anything
about it
ramsay's theorem yeah uh you know
um ram say no i never had a class of
ramsey theorem and that's what that was
in some sense uh
a career challenge for me uh because i
mean
it's an incredible theorem it's it's a
credible complete function how come
there is nothing
there is uh there is uh there is a
a wonderful powerful paper by money now
and authors that essentially talk about
ramsay
i many of my students have read it
but but it's too hard for me okay you
know but
but but some many of my students have
explained and also
michalis has explained it to me and they
they sort of talk you know they have a
lot of interesting results about ramsey
and i believe that michalis and a
student
have been trying to you know have been
successful actually in classifying
ramsey
sort of in some class that combines
total functions with induction or
something okay you know so so i have not
seen the paper yet
uh but i mean oh that's a that's that's
a great you know we
uh the lower bound for ramsey okay sort
of you know the erdes
you know the original erdes uh sort of
uh
existence or probabilistic method proof
uh
uh that one is in our class a pep so we
know and
and we we talk about it in our in our
uh in our uh uh
uh paper but not not not
not not the true ramsey
existence proof
so i guess sorry
scientific so i guess the ramsey's
theorem
would that be in quasi-polynomial time
just on the surface because you could
try it
theorem has also the uh we know it's
quasar
is definitely quasi-polynomial time so
it does not have the same stature and
and and uh expectations as the other as
the other sort of
tough nuts in this in this realm you're
right
uh sorry to
about amino this this presumably should
make it easier to classify
right i mean but but but you don't know
how to classify it
right okay
um so tony has a question do you want to
ask it tony to yourself
if not well
i'll speak up for case sounds the word
for so tony tony ann asks isn't it
complete for
vc dim this is ramsey i guess
it must be ramsey's theorem
uh i don't um believe it or not i don't
know this class i have not defined this
class so i'm not i'm not
responsible for knowing it okay i'm
joking yeah
oh i see vc dimension oh i see it
yeah okay okay i know i know there is i
know i know a result like that
yes right yeah you know and this
dimension is
close to our you know but so i know i
uh interesting okay okay
uh so i um
i think there was a result like that at
some point tony's right
yeah so you know i i should look it up i
i forget what it is exactly
okay
so as the maybe the final question for
me is there any
anything in ttfnp or tf6 sigma 2p that
the sat community should be looking at
in terms of uh
generating interesting proofs or
is there connections to proof search
okay so
um uh is there anything
you know what i'll tell you i'll tell
you i'll tell you i'll tell you one
observation that is that is that is
uh that also happens to be you know
oliver corten uh pointed this out to me
a long time ago
uh before coming to columbia
uh that there is a there is a secret
connection between uh proof
systems like let's say uh cook raccoon
uh complete proof systems and
and tfnp in the sense that they are
identical
so you know you can see a problem in fnp
as as mapping to a formula to
a dn to cnf that sort of um it's
equivalent okay sorry we know but uh but
it turns out
and then the ku krakow proof system is
also a map of
uh to cnf okay and the point is that
complete proof systems in other words
the things that that that that they give
you give you
that have proofs coincide with tfnp
that has always has a witness okay so
uh so amino
there is there is this this very
interesting connection between proof
systems and and
and and and tfp which
i don't know if everybody knows it or
not so you know but it's very simple and
and uh
so um
what else uh i mean uh
uh you guys sort of you know sad
is is uh is uh
sort of the pinnacle of of everything so
you know so
so i mean you can't i mean all of uh
all the rest of us or you know are uh
are looking up to it sort of you know
and you are working on it okay so so
that's
that's that's uh uh
uh i mean you are way ahead of us okay
that's
in that sense you know
so sat is the base is the basis of
everything we do
okay i think your audience is sold on
that last comment
so very good all right
okay so let's uh let's thank christos
again unless there's some last minute
jumped in question
and uh otherwise thank you again so much
for the talk and attending
you know everyone can clap along with me
if you can't see them
and um thank you so much so we're going
to take a
short break of about five minutes and
we'll start up about let's see it's
i have 9 23 so it's 23 after the hour
right now
for most of us and so we'll start up at
53
sorry 28 i can add 28 after the hour
with ryan speaking so i'll see you guys
back shortly
um and christos thank you again
thank you thank you thanks everybody